l'opération drapeau blanc pour un
week-end moins meurtrier sur les routes
un premier bilan tout à l'heure avec
claude sérillon rebondissement dans la
sphère de la pilule abortive le ministre
de la santé impose à roussel uclaf de la
remettre sur le marché
les évêques protestent à nouveau
polémique en métropole regain de tension
sur le terrain la situation en
nouvelle-calédonie à quinze jours du
référendum
israël vote dans quatre jours l'armée
resserre son emprise sur les territoires
occupés au tableau d'honneur de la
semaine l'homme qui met la grande
cuisine sur orbite
là monsieur bonsoir
quand la polémique mêle des arguments de
santé publique et des pressions morales
ou religieuses
quand la stratégie commerciale prend le
pas sur le progrès médical
quand la santé physique et psychologique
des femmes par millions et pas seulement
en france est en jeu
quand enfin il s'agit d'avortement tous
les ingrédients sont là pour transformer
un produit pharmaceutique en affaire
nationale
la pilule abortive ru486 va être à
nouveau mise sur le marché
ainsi en a décidé le ministre de la
santé claude evin qui vient d'enjoindre
le groupe où c'est luc lave de revenir
sur sa décision de retirer le produit
la raison invoquée l'intérêt de la santé
publique véronique sainteny à la bouse
le coup de théâtre provient de ces trois
comprimés le ru486 il y à 48 heures le
médicaments abortifs mise au point dans
ce laboratoire de l'hôpital bicêtre est
quasiment interdit de circulation
le groupe roussel uclaf suspend la vente
de la pilule abortive ru486 arguments
avancés par le laboratoire
pharmaceutique des pressions morales
venant des lobbys anti avortement et
puis aussi pour ne pas risquer de perdre
sa place sur le marché des médicaments
américain aujourd'hui retournement de
situation le ministère de la santé
décide d'intervenir
j'ai considéré
qu'à partir du moment où ce progrès
existent pour les femmes de notre pays
je dirais presque moralement
le produit était devenu quasiment
moralement propriété les femmes et qu'à
partir du moment où il ya un progrès à
partir du moment où on peut par des
moyens nouveaux permettre qu'il y ait
moins de souffrance pour les femmes en
l'occurrence là aussi une manière
générale pour mes hommes pour nos
concitoyens qu'il y ait moins de
souffrance il était de ma responsabilité
de le dire c'est ce que j'ai dit au
groupe ou celle du claf les milieux
médicaux réagissent favorablement à
cette intervention directe du
gouvernement mais c'est la douche froide
pour certains milieux catholiques
j'ai tout de même un peu stupide vous
m'aimez pas cru dans un premier temps il
faudrait qu'on me répète misant demain
dans notre pays dans un groupe que je
croyais libre mise en demeure et au nom
de la santé publique parce que c'est un
médicament considéré publiquement
officiellement dream act est pareil que
le rugby est un médicament autrement dit
tranquillement que la grossesse commence
en tête une maladie les laboratoires
roussel uclaf ont donc décidé
d'obtempérer
toujours pour raisons morales mais cette
fois surtout pour raison d'état ce débat
vient de se tenir par médias interposés
il vient d'être sanctionné par une
décision d'ordre politique c'est à dire
par une décision d'ordre public à partir
de ce moment là je crois que tout le
monde est bien obligé de s'incliner par
deux
décision prise puisque le ru486 est donc
revenue dans le camp des femmes
on l'avait un peu vite oublié mais le
ru486
c'est avant tout une histoire de femmes
oui si monseigneur de courtrai menace
donc de mettre en oeuvre tout son
pouvoir contre une décision qui selon
lui ne sert que le libéralisme sauvage
ce sont les termes qu'il a employés le
groupe roussel uclaf s'est donc rendu à
la décision politique le produit qui
avait été agréée le mois dernier n'est
utilisable vous le savez que dans des
centres spécialisés et plusieurs femmes
ont déjà été traitées ainsi daniel
duigou cette femme de 20 ans est l'une
des premières à avoir utilisé la pilule
abortive
elle est toujours suivi régulièrement
par son gynécologue son choix au delà de
la polémique actuelle elle n'explique
pour des raisons bien précis pour éviter
la liste ici
et puis l'aspiration qu'elle fait un peu
peur et je ferai traumatisante
dans 95 % des cas le ru486 a prouvé
jusqu'à maintenant son efficacité il
s'administre dix jours environ après le
retard des règles et deux à trois jours
après l'avortement se remarque par un
simple saignement et une petite douleur
mais dans 5% des cas la pilule abortive
n'est pas efficace et c'est pourquoi la
femme doit accepter deux conditions sont
la première condition est l'acceptation
d'une éventuelle intervention secondaire
j'avais une aspiration sous anesthésie
locale ou générale en cas d'échec du
ru486 soit parce que la grossesse
continue complètement soit parce qu'il
existe une rétention de l'oeuvre dans
l'utérus qui se manifeste par des
hémorragies qui peuvent être plus ou
moins importantes
la deuxième condition c'est accepter un
examen pour vérifier qu'on n'est pas en
présence d'une grossesse extra utérine
mais depuis la commercialisation de la
pilule aucune complication n'a été
constatée chez l'ensemble des femmes
soumises à cette nouvelle méthode
d'avortement les réactions multiples et
contradictoires que la décision de
claude evin provoque ce soir laisse à
penser que la polémique n'est pas close
13 ans donc après la loi de madame veil
sur l'interruption volontaire dé
grossesse pression et passion demeure
roussel uclaf disaient les avoir subi
pour justifier le retrait du produit
mais c'est surtout aux etats-unis qui
représentent un énorme marché pour tous
les produits du groupe que la campagne a
été la plus virulente
il n'ya pas aux états unis de loi
fédérale sur l'avortement et c'est même
l'une des questions clés de la campagne
présidentielle actuelle paul nahon
voici l'homme qui sur la côte est des
états unis préparent les grandes
manifestations anti avortement de ces
prochains jours
il s'appelle kirk vander swag il est
pasteur et c'est avec l'aide de la bible
qu'il tente de rallier une majorité
d'américains à son mouvement sauver les
bébés depuis plusieurs mois déjà les
manifestations anti avortement succèdent
aux manifestations ici atlanta en
georgie où depuis longtemps les
cliniques où l'on à bord sont assiégées
les forces de l'ordre ont chargé et ces
images ont choqué l'amérique brutalité
policière face à cette montée
d'intolérance il y a peu de chances que
dans ce climat la pilule abortive soit
mise en vente aux états unis
je reconnais que c'est une façon plus
sûre de pratiquer l'avortement mais on
n'en connaît pas encore toutes les
conséquences
c'est vrai que c'est plus acceptable
mais cela reste un avortement
vous êtes content cette pilule
absolument sans oublier dans ce débat
qui divise l'amérique la position des
deux candidats à la maison blanche
george bush résolument opposée à
l'avortement sauf dans les cas d'inceste
et de viol
my duc actis lui en faveur de
l'avortement c'est à dire pour un libre
choix de la femme c'est 400 le groupe
roussel uclaf qu'elles ont accepté de
reprendre la diffusion de son produit en
france ne s'est pas engagé à le
commercialiser à l'étranger il demande
maintenant l'aval de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé qui avaient des
enfants testés contre le retrait du
produit
les comptes de la sécurité sociale sont
en meilleur état que prévu en cette fin
d'année le déficit reste malgré tout de
10 milliards de francs et le ministre de
la santé et de la sécurité sociale a
confirmé aujourd'hui la reconduction
prochaine de la cotisation 2
4 % sur le revenu imposable est le
relèvement de 1 % de la cotisation
vieillesse arrestation de l'incendiaire
du cinéma saint michel à paris ce cinéma
qui projetait vous le savez la tentation
du christ il s'appelle thomas lagourgue
il a 25 ans sans emploi il a reconnu les
faits il est ce soir sous mandat de
dépôt transports en commun air france ou
yard lorraine françoise joly et nicolas
jacobs se font maintenant le point sur
les conflits sociaux
d'abord cette réaction de mauvaise
humeur cet après midi mais les mineurs
lorrains ont fini par accepter de
suspendre la grève jusqu'à mercredi
prochain après plus de deux heures de
négociations avec la direction ils ont
obtenu 50 francs de plus par mois il en
demandait quatre cent cinquante métro et
bus à l'arrêt à lyon aujourd'hui pour le
troisième jour consécutif grève totale
des transports en commun les conducteurs
ont refusé l'augmentation de trois pour
cent des salaires proposés par la
direction
ce soir les syndicats ont appelé à la
poursuite du mouvement des manifestants
sur les pistes d'orly c'était ce matin
les mécaniciens au sol d'air france sont
en grève depuis plus d'une semaine il
demande 1500 francs de plus
et l'embauché de personnel
supplémentaire six avions sont
immobilisés mais sans conséquences pour
les voyageurs
la grève se poursuit au centre de tri
postal de lille les haines et plusieurs
entreprises sont en difficulté dans le
nord
la concertation au sein de l'audiovisuel
public après les employeurs hier madame
tasca a reçu aujourd'hui les syndicats
la négociation salariale dans la
fonction publique reprendra le 8
novembre prochain la cgt maintient son
projet d'une journée nationale d'action
autour de ces dates et de son côté andré
bergeron prédite au gouvernement de
nouveaux conflits sociaux dans la
fonction publique et les entreprises
nationalisées
si les concessions ne sont pas faites à
l'assemblée nationale après celui de la
justice un deuxième budget recalé par
les députés l'examen du budget des
anciens combattants est reportée pour la
première fois depuis leur duel électoral
de mai dernier françois mitterrand et
jacques chirac se sont rencontrés
aujourd'hui une poignée de main purement
protocolaire vous venez de voir
de l'état inaugurait un monument à paris
à la mémoire de berty albrecht la grande
résistante qui anima avec henri freiner
le mouvement combat pluie d'épithètes et
de petites phrases meeting et polémiques
la campagne pour le référendum du 6
novembre s'accélère en métropole sur le
terrain en nouvelle calédonie le climat
serait dit al'approche du scrutin
dominique terre c'est dominique merlin
ont plongé en brousse en plein milieu
caldoches le regard tourné vers ce qui
serait bientôt la ligne de partage entre
les provinces nord et sud
un ruisseau au milieu des arbres le criq
amic sur ses rives quelques éleveurs qui
deviendront électeurs dans l'une ou
l'autre des provinces celles du nord à
majorité mélanésienne et
indépendantistes celle du sud
essentiellement blanche et en tient des
pendentifs bernard gaud soins serait lui
dans le futur découpage rattaché à la
province nord mais cela ne l'inquiète
pas au contraire les solides et à la
livre n'a pas remis ils sont dans le nom
qu'ils ont besoin de la solidarité
et si on veut rester en calédonie si on
veut rester français sur la grille
données responsable il faudrait
solidaires les avions et moi le chant
guerrier incroyable je suis content d
des petits broussard le couple go soins
ils ont à peine le nécessaire pas d'eau
courante pas d'électricité depuis 20 ans
ils ont vécu bien des mésaventures
depuis 84 expulsion bétail abattu coup
de fusil les accords de matignon pour
eux c'est une lueur d'espoir mais pour
le référendum du 6 novembre prochain ils
sont bien indécis moi même j'ai toujours
prôné puisque
on y est mais l'adhésion on a tout donné
on a tous les outils
bon bon bon mais je dirais presque le
même trouvant parce qu'il n'y a pas eu
de reconnaissance pour nous j'ai des
doutes sur la sincérité de monsieur
tibaous et du fnrs
alors votez oui c'est vraiment leur
donner toute ma confiance alors que je
suis persuadé qu'ils vont conférer au
balo et m'abstenir
je voudrais pas protégé thomas l'accord
je ne sais pas si je vais peut-être que
le vôtre et oui je voudrais aussi je
vais voter je voudrais ici sinon je
m'abstiendrai mais j'irai pas pour voter
non
sinon je m'abstiendrai parce que nous
sommes abstenus
je suis pas contre puis j'ai pas
l'habitude de me dérober des mes
responsabilités mais ce qui me fait peur
c'est sur ces effets des crises j'ai pas
confiance
j'ai subi trou deux fois et j'ai pas
ils sont nombreux ici à ne pas trop y
croire tiraillé de plus entre les
consignes d'abstention du rpr et celles
de sa filiale locale le rpr qui prônent
le oui j'en de l'ouvrier a fait son
choix par pragmatisme
lui aussi a des raisons d'être inquiet
c'était sa maison incendiée il y a
quelques mois nous calédonienne n'avons
pas le droit même si on appartient au
rpc et on n'a pas le droit nous
moralement n'a pas le droit de suivre
l'attitude du père par exemple pourquoi
parce que le affaire a pris ses
décisions sur des raisons politiques
mais nous il ya autre chose qui passe
avant ces questions politiques de dire
c'est la paix la sécurité dont la
tranquillité dans le territoire la paix
la tranquillité retrouvée
c'est l'argument des partisans du oui au
référendum sur les bords du cric amic
comme partout ailleurs sur le territoire
l'argument pourrait être démontée au
moindre dérapage
62% des français n'ont pas l'intention
d'aller voter le 6 novembre d'après le
sondage sofres que publiera demain le
figaro le taux d'abstention 38% aurait
donc baisser d'un point par rapport au
précédent sondage sofres nouvel
observateur en corse le climat politique
est à la décrispation
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
lionel jospin qui vient de passer deux
jours dans l'île a annoncé diverses
mesures qui répondent aux aspirations
culturelles des corses généralisation de
l'étude de leur langue à tous les
niveaux du système scolaire et création
des 90 d'un capes de corse
le ministre a cependant refusé que tous
les emplois d'enseignants soient
réservés à des insulaires le
renforcement de l'identité corse qui
tient au coeur de lille chantal
kimmerlin l'a vérifié à l'université de
corte créant 80 accueille maintenant
1800 étudiants corte au coeur de la
montagne corse c'est un pari lancé il ya
sept ans retenir les étudiants sur l'île
les attirer pour cinq ans au moins dans
un village de paysans et de bergers
aujourd'hui le pari a presque réussi de
tirs des étudiants corses choisissent
corte pour faire leurs études
une fille plus sur le continent pour
beaucoup c'est un choix difficile
un acte deux fois sinon du militantisme
une mise en place d'une ne plus la mise
en place d'une politique par le
gouvernement qui veut qui permettent
justement une valorisation de la
l'université de corte provoquant cesse
de considérer ça comme une université un
peu folklorique comme quelque chose qui
était donné comme ça aux corses pour
leur faire plaisir
beaucoup reste à faire l'université
n'est pas adapté à lille et à ses futurs
besoins économiques
mais lille elle non plus n'est pas prête
à recevoir et à faire travailler des
jeunes de plus en plus diplômés
aujourd'hui sur le campus on préfère
taire les luttes politiques et obéir à
la loi du silence car les étudiants de
corte reste toujours des corses
déterminée ne sont peut-être un tournant
de notre histoire de sport de l'accord
histoire d'université il ne faut pas que
nous
il ne faut pas que nos relations ont
valu négocier au mieux et si on négocie
c'est discuter avec monsieur jospin
discute ya beaucoup de gens qui assurent
cycle terre nous nous sommes prêts alors
que l'ouverture nous sommes les premiers
les premiers soit sale cette ouverture
c'est comme une voix nationalistes qui a
prôné l'ouverture qu'il est l'attrait
des attentes a été décrétée par le mans
nationaliste les discours politiques
socialistes qui défait la motion sur le
peuple corse et les vins du mouvement
nationaliste
donc nous sommes conscients que s'il
faut créer nous sommes là pour créer
nationalisme dans le dialogue et la
sérénité
aujourd'hui corte n'est plus un campus à
haut risque il a choisi sa voie celle de
la tente et de la confiance
rohff le policière en allemagne fédérale
dans les milieux palestiniens
quatorze personnes ont été interpellées
quatre ont été arrêtées pour préparation
d'attentât est un important arsenal a
été saisie il s'agirait de partisans des
jebril basée à damas en israël c'est une
vingtaine de journalistes et de
syndicalistes palestiniens qui ont été
arrêtés aujourd'hui je l aime est et en
cisjordanie
les élections israéliennes ont lieu dans
quatre jours
et l'armée investit plus énergiquement
les territoires occupés sur place
martine laroche-joubert gilbert usant
pour le premier mort du corps farah en
cisjordanie depuis le début du
soulèvement palestinien une
manifestation à sa mémoire 17 ans tué
d'une balle en plastique la semaine
dernière et déjà enterré par destine
mois les slogans dans la mort dans le
sens vaincra
l'unique espoir de victoire qui les fait
avancer même si certains suivait de loin
les élections en israël quelques arabes
préfèrent shimon peres
parce qu'il souhaite une conférence
internationale pour la paix mais
peut-être que ce ne sont que des
promesses électorales pas puisque ça eq
après sa victoire il ne reconnaîtra pas
le droit d arabes à leur
autodétermination à droits légitimes
mais face à l'armée des femmes jettent
des cailloux par terre les jeunes les
ramasse et les lancent sur les soldats
la riposte suis instantanément
ils balancent des grenades lacrymogènes
certains palestiniens qui n des
cocktails molotov nahmad qui permettent
aux soldats d'user du droit de légitime
défense
mais il n'y aura pas de blessés
aujourd'hui nous remarquons cependant
que les femmes et les enfants sont en
première ligne
le couvre-feu est imposé
il nous faut partir rapidement c'était
une journée ordinaire dans les
territoires occupés un vendredi jour de
prière demain il y aura grève générale
en cisjordanie et à gaza à l'appel du
comité clandestins du soulèvement mais
aussi d organisation intégriste les
territoires occupés sont donc sous très
haute surveillance
avec en perspective bien sûr les
élections de mardi prochain et des feux
est sur orbite le tir d'ariane a été
superbement réussi
quant aux images de haute définition qui
vont être diffusés par ce satellite
vous pourrez les capter en janvier 89
emmanuel vanier la télé de demain est
sur orbite
ariane 2 et tf1 ont parfaitement rempli
leur mission 23 lancements réussis sur
26 pour ariane elle confirme ainsi sa
fiabilité
les collages la nuit dernière de kourou
25 minutes plus tard tdf un déployer
parfaitement ses panneaux solaires une
manoeuvre délicate qui avait provoqué la
perte de son jumeau allemand l'an
dernier les df1 c'est un public
potentiel de 400 millions de
téléspectateurs en janvier prochain
mais pour l'instant une seule chaîne à
réserver conte son canal l'a7 la chaîne
culturelle européenne
burhan la tempête de neige c'est son nom
décollera demain matin de baïkonour
un rapide aller retour dans l'espace la
navette soviétique effectuera deux
orbites avant de regagner la terre en
fin de matinée pas d'équipage pour ce
vol entièrement automatisée à lancement
exceptionnel couverture exceptionnelle
sur antenne 2 flash spécial à 8h20
demain matin et au cours des journaux le
volet le retour sur faire de la première
navette spatiale soviétique
37 morts dans un avion atr-42 c'était il
ya un an près de milan le juge italien
vient d'inculper neuf personnes
d'homicide involontaire
parmi elles l'un des ingénieurs de
l'aérospatiale l'un des concepteurs de
la théière 42 le juge a estimé que le
système anti glace de cet appareil était
inadapté c'est l'accumulation de givre
qui aurait provoqué sa chute
cette inculpation à cette accusation
sont en quelque sorte une remise en
cause de la fiabilité de cet avion
franco-italien déjà vendu à plus de 200
exemplaires
retournons sur orbite et par là aux
cuisines à notre tableau d'honneur de
cette semaine un chef
le chef de l'année d'ailleurs il vient
d'être élu par ses pairs marc meneau
bonsoir bonsoir les tous les gourmets
savent que vous officiez à saint pair
sur vez et dans l'yonne
et c'est vous qui allez préparer les
délicieux petits plats auxquels ont
droit les hausses mono du prochain vol
spécial franco soviétique alors comment
vous est venue cette idée d'une
spécialisé dans la cuisine spatiale bien
c'est fait a fait du hasard
autour d'une table d'amis avec patrick
baudry un avis scientifique
en effet en train de consommer et celui
ci a donc trouvé que les plats étaient
meilleurs que ceux qu'ils pouvaient
déguster en apesanteur et on s'est fait
un petit pari entre nous de pouvoir
réussir à faire une nourriture qui se
rapprocherait de celle que l'on mange
sur terre et de celles que l'on mange
entre autres dans les restaurants alors
concrètement comment allez vous faire
pour condenser et tout à voir des
produits frais surtout alors les
produits près bien sûr ne sont pas
concevoir puisque on est donc parti pour
un certain temps que ce soit pour un
espace pour d'autres aventures
donc on a cherché à enfermer dans des
boîtes appertisés des produits
alimentaires qui pouvait retrouver ou
faire retrouver aux gens qui les
consommer le goût de ce qu'ils avaient
quand il était en situation normale
alors je demande c'est l'heure du dîner
une idée du menu spatiale que vous
préparez alors le type même a été de
trouver des aliments qu'ils soient
facilement assimilable dans tout dans le
cas de pesanteur et qui soit
relativement liquide pour certains parce
qu'ils ont des difficultés de
déglutition et c'est pour ça qu'on a
créé des tubes et qui sont assez faciles
à manger où on trouve des aliments comme
des crèmes de crevettes comme des
pectine de pomme comme des crêpes au
chocolat et tous à antibes alors en tue
et d'autre d'autres concernent ont été
mis en boîte et on y ajoutait le plaisir
du pain le plaisir de gâteaux et de
plaisir de pigeons lentilles de quoi
faire revivre un aventurier à ces
moments de terre de bonheur et donc en
somme c'est bon pour le moral comme
chacun sait moins pour le moral je pense
oui
alors que no mercy le grand prix bonsoir
le tennis bercy cet après-midi lors des
quarts de finale le dernier français guy
forget a été éliminé en deux sets par
l'américain brad gilbert autres
qualifiés pour les demi-finales
l'israëlien man sort vainqueur
d'américains crutzen les autres
rencontres et le résultat sur antenne ou
tout à l'heure vers 23h30 un torrent de
passion pour terminer ce journal en
beauté avec les premières images que
michel pascal a obtenu pour nous en
exclusivité ce sont celles du film
camille claudel produit est jouée par
isabelle adjani cinq mois et demi de
tournage sortie le 7 décembre prochain
un avant goût
d'ici là bas
dur
ma source d'inspiration
qu'est ce que la cage mais le mois
toi et moi c'est pas pareil somme de
révolte de la nature
m
je suis claudel et si vous l'ignorez
star violemment et l'orgueil
voilà où elle est violente ce n'est que
parce qu'elle est passionnée
mystère en place hier matin condamné
l'attentât
délectation et ses pertes et à contenir
oui
et
tous
la vanille et dans le rôle de randa vous
avez reconnu bien sûr gérard depardieu
le long week-end de la toussaint
commencent ce soir pour beaucoup d'entre
vous cinq millions huit français sont
attendus sur les routes et beaucoup de
drapeaux blancs j'espère pour signaler
votre participation à notre opération
sécurité routière qui va donc durer
jusqu'à mardi prochain alors que lens et
lyon il ya c'est déjà un premier bilan
depuis tout à l'heure
christine on peut faire une première
comptabilité vous et je vais me dépasser
je vais près d'un compteur en 1983
c'était la même configuration c'était
une même toussaint qui tombe un mardi
oscillant à peu près le même temps le
même le nombre de personnes qu'on
attendait sur les routes en 83 il y
avait eu 189 accidents corporels au bout
de trois heures
cette comptabilité que je vous propose
c'est au bout de trois heures voilà la
comparaison 189 accident 80 342 cette
année c'est déjà beaucoup
on se tuer en 83 6 morts en 88 c'est
beaucoup trop et les blessés 292 165
c'est un petit peu moins effectivement
c'est légèrement encourageant je dirais
que si je voulais employés une un
vocabulaire électorale c'est un
frémissement mais on est très très loin
du compte
évidemment au bout de trois heures il y
a déjà beaucoup trop de tuer beaucoup
trop de blessés et puis le nombre de
porteurs de drapeaux blancs avant de
rappeler le nombre de vies sauvées
nombre de porteurs de drapeaux blancs
c'est pas très très très encourageant il
faut bien reconnaître on est avant 10 %
à 6 % de porter drapeau blanc
c'est très léger bon c'est vrai qu'on a
commencé qu'on attendait de vous
sensibilisez vous qui prenez la route à
partir de ce soir jusqu'à mercredi
portait un drapeau blanc a noué un
chiffon blanc bon on n'a pas encore
complètement réussi on a pour sa 2 3 4
jours pour le faire voilà le nombre de
vies sauvées ce soir nous sommes à cinq
vies sauvées
c'est très peu c'est très peu et il faut
faire évidemment beaucoup plus alors
s'il vous plaît rejoignez nous pour
cette opération drapeau blanc je
reprendrai un slogan et christine vous
êtes comme moi on va faire le geste de
noué un chiffon blanc à l'antenne de
notre voiture surtout n'ayez pas peur du
ridicule car le ridicule lui ne tue pas
et il faut que ces chiffres soient bien
meilleure ce soir à 21h30 avec gérard
holtz et bernard pivot et puis à 23h15
pour un deuxième point dans la soirée
merci claude et du blanc moi j'en porte
même ce soir les pronostics de pierrette
brès pour
le car s'est d'evry demain le cincle 17
le 9 le 2 le 15 le 18 le 8 et le 16
henri sannier vous présentera notre
dernier journal en direct de lille tout
à l'heure puisqu'il participe lui aussi
à l'opération en drapeau blanc bien sûr
de tout à l'heure sophie davant va vous
parler du temps de demain et du temps
pour ce week end et peut-être pour le
très long pont de la toussaint de mal et
rendez vous d'information avec daniel
bilalian philippe gassot et bien sûr
bernard rapp très bonne soirée bon week
end à la semaine prochaine